on est avec berges en salon sont tus
vocal m donc vous avez tous ramené un
trésor que vous avez trouvé dans votre
maison c'est vrai et je peux vous dire
qu'ils ont ramené du très très lourd
pierre-jean tu vas estimé à chaque fois
l'objet abbas
avec jérôme et jérôme nous dira voilà
que je lui dirai je te dirai si la
raison ou tort d'accord parce qu'il est
très de son expert de l'expert alors on
va démarrer par un premier objet si ça
alors j'ai mathieu d'amande amère
j'ai donc on va tuer qui fait qu'elle
est obligée alors cet objet dans mon
salon wima j'ai mis des fêtes dans mon
salon j'ai mes différentes photos de moi
plusieurs âges
alors qu est donc celle là c'est un fan
qui l'a prise d'une photo que j'avais
prise de moi même en vacances avec moi
du coup il c'est un fan et qui la nuit
comme ça et du coup je les ai mis dans
le salon et je la trouve assez joli
parce qu'elle est proche de la réalité
oui si les couleurs sont belles sont pas
pardon mais la paysage était pas mal en
tout cas
l'expression est quelque chose il
s'agirait du charisme et yamamah c'est
bon à votre avis est ce que voulaient le
toucher fin à leurs jours
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors désir est de bien regarder si
elles pas un montage comme maintenant
y'a pas les billets sur toutes ses
berges en y accueillons pas de photoshop
donc cette enquête interne on sait
devoir ici à davos et écoute c'est assez
déco ouais là dernier une fois j'étais
venu j'avais acheté une photo de toi
dédicacé j'avais payé dieval way dans
ces eaux là à quoi est-ce que vous
souhaitez de réseau la seychelles
j'aurais l'original plus tard
mais j'avoue que cette âme ouais moi je
mettrais allez c'est pas pour te faire
plaisir mais franchement je souhaiterais
100 euros ça discrédite toute ta
carrière
c'est des cours mes enfants et puis
c'est comme un des grands atouts de
napoléon oui mais aussi des deux autres
voilà lui après napoléon
c'était à la bataille de marengo ah oui
j'avais mangé du poulet tu vois alors ça
va déraper rhénan s'emballe alors c'est
vous qui avez donné s'emballe à matthew
pc comme à faire conclut il comptait pas
seulement son filet à moitié cachée dans
l'anglais chabal et souple voilà merci
mathieu sa version route ne servait à
rien c'est bon alors est la confiance
revient
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors ça c'est la lourdeur l'objet de
jean michel a slip c'est cool non
oui mais l'intéressant c'est le côté
mais sa base et la tâche ses droits ces
barges à lèvres c'était malheureusement
c'est des années 90 je savais que je ne
mets jamais le plus jamais le caleçon
oui ce slip était le dernier bal aussi
pour sa valeur historique
c'est bien et steptoe jimmy il est sale
j'ai pas c'est pas une saleté c'est une
trace de rouge à lèvres explique ses
tics devils années 90 c'était le début
on le sexe devenait décomplexé au sirop
teasé et j'étais avec une jeune femme
est en face on devenait mon épouse après
et voilà et on faisait petit jeu c'est u
9 se mais d'une extrême kuzawa ma future
épouse exactement que j'embrasse et
voilà et ont joué le faisait à peu le
tigre par terre comme ça et je lui donne
un petit coup de fouet comme ça mais ça
va aller sauter des frontières sera pas
de frosties non et on joue et moi je
faisais sûrement avoir un fou et je
tapais comme ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est en ça que sophie davant important
si c'était ma future femme c'était pas
ma copine de l'époque j'avais une autre
copine à l'époque aulas alors c'était ma
maîtresse même et tracy alors la vie
après celle de ma femme après voilà et
voilà on jouant comme ça elle s'approcha
de moi est avec ses jouets des excédents
de sa prochaine machine skrzypek et donc
d'où les traces de rouge à lèvres sur
ces points comme ça elle m'a arraché
mais c'est long c'est bon maintenant
risques importants évidemment quand je
rentrais chez moi en déshabillant ma
femme a vu enfin ma copine et a vu des
traces de rouge à lèvres par cosa ultra
le rongeait sur le trou vous pouvez dire
sa voisine copine de 5e qui l'a filmé en
vous embrassant sur le style c'est plus
compliqué d'où la pêche mais s'il pourra
quoi mais c'était un frère jean 0/15 où
notre amitié
non non c'est bon pour notre amitié je
préfère ne rien de ne rien vous pouvez
le mettre
alors je suis trop grosse non reprenez
votre slip là allez merci on y va il va
regarder sans ramener alors maxime est
ce que tu peux nous expliquer leur geste
sans michel s'il vous plaît
jean-michel je suis fan de l'époque
médiévale depuis que j'ai vu les
visiteurs en 93
ça vous plaît vraiment le vendre ah
ouais avant son prénom de jacquouille et
godefroy le hardi vous avez la petite
épée je fais les quelques
reconstitutions chaque fois aussi
tuterai pas si j'ai faibli et j'avais
remis à chaque numéro un comme ça dans
une brocante à côté de la forêt de
montmirail
alors j'ai vu un signe je n'ai acheté et
je me suis dit pourquoi pas combien vous
avez acheté ça a dû 15 m d'euros
bright et ben ça vaut pas plus
[Rires]
alors est ce que vous voulez l'étendre
au web en valeur les gens pensent que 15
euros à 0 sec 1/10 vraiment lé qu'ils
distribuent pas la monnaie du bal il
lève la main il veut plus
est-ce qu'il a un mois mon cadeau c'est
moi à bas prix sur un chèque cadeau non
merci il avait bizarre il a oublié mais
je pensais qu'il y avait une valeur
historique derrière un hystérique oui
sur balles voit là bas il a perdu de
losail gilad shalit ulrich bien mais
tout ça dans ta manette qui claquent
dans ta manette voilà combien alors on a
vendu son global questions morales
cibouriens ne savons rien j'ai passé là
mais tu peux le mettre là bas attention
on a alors commencé à voir de beaux
objets à regarder valérie bénaïm a
ramené un succès parce que vous avez
alors attention parce que il ya une
valeur et familiale
c'est le sèche cheveux de la famille des
femmes de la famille ben ali
il a dû chauffer sûrs et il a travaillé
depuis les années 60 il a chauffé les
cheveux de votre arrière-arrière-arrière
oiseaux sentirait pas mon
arrière-grand-mère n'exagérons pas avait
déjà des mâles grand mère déjà oui déjà
pas mal comment ma grand mère elle
s'appelait à décrire à l'écrire on sait
maintenant qu'aucun grand père aussi
métaux lourds
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
d'accord ma grand mère ma maman mes
cheveux trois générations de femmes
en plus je trouve qu'il est le symbole
d'une époque les femmes qui commençait à
s'émanciper et commencer à prendre soin
d'elle au pouvoir sortir à l'extérieur
du foyer magnifique objet donc combien
ça combien une belle histoire j'ai du
mal à donner un prix parce que c'est
quand même super si lente alors je
voudrais 10 euros non mais c'est vrai un
objet non par sylla était vintage il
fallait qu'ils soient dans les années 50
que l'acheteur exquis mais 550 donc ses
dix balles ont déjà pu chausser bien
payer 10 euros 10 balles voilà attention
attention passe à un autre objet voilà
qu'un mythe et s'asseoir à table de
pierre-jean tout ça c'est à toi ah ben
là là les gars là les gars on a un très
bel objet alors racontez nous c'est
l'objet de benjamin castaldi est là à
ses ténors
alors c'est un serseri table césar c'est
que a rapporté ma grand-mère en soi oui
pour la vie devant soi
elle était trop belle la chance d'avoir
cet objet sur ma chemise je les amenais
donc c'est simone signoret à votre
grand-mère à ce que les gens connaissent
bien un petit clin d'oeil parce que je
pense que ça n'a pas de prix
ah ouais observant comment ça se
vendrait sa ce que je ça n'a pas de prix
c'est vrai c'est assez exceptionnel
césar en plus est mort et puis c'est
quand même simone signoret ouais c'est
quand même notre super méga star
française ça n'a pas de prix mais bon tu
as toujours un prix un con mais à peu
près moi je suis pas moi je mettrai ça
aujourd'hui l'envié voulait le vendre
pour récupérer de l'argent
je souhaiterais mais si je devais mettre
une estimation raisonnable
je m et 80 cents milles 1
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le rsa je tiens à remercier remercier
aux lumières jean-françois bichot
également aux décors philippe beauchamp
mais sur le symbole sardin beurre
c'est simone signoret ticket on a
souvent pris de fabrication de 1000
euros est normalement un scénario mini
mais c'est un autre comme les oscars au
départ ou non je veux faire c'est mieux
de le faire ça vaut entre 500 millions
et les oscars toutes les couleurs si on
perd on peut pas le garder sous kelly a
ramené un très bel objet également
qu'est ce que c'est que ça christine
kelly une médaille alors que vous avez
trouvé dans votre maison c'est vraiment
un trésor dans votre maison
oui c'est l'ordre national du mérite que
j'ai reçus par gérard larcher en 2010
alors pour ne rien vous cacher pour vous
parler franchement pas ce qu'on va me
prendre pour une débile j'ai laissé ma
vraie médaille à la maison donc on l'a
remplacé par sam et mais on va dire que
c'est l'ordre national du mérite pour
mais mon travail dont les médias et elle
le mérite
le mérite mais comme c'est pas là la
médaille célèbre madame c'est une scène
bien que tu as reçu quand même
non pas celle là celle là bon parce que
c'est toi 20 euros je t'adore
c'est bien elle est dix balles
[Rires]
être offerts non je travaille avec toi
et tu vas voir tu t'appelles regarder ce
qu'elle a ramené à alors c'est ça ça ça
va se vendre cher ça un ca je sais pas
ce que c'est une voie tad entier non non
ne donnant pas déjà jérôme c'est une
petite crèche et c'est son histoire qui
la rend inestimable alors je vous
explique ça c'est un copain qui fait de
l'humanitaire qui la trouve au mexique
comme dans les décombres d'une maison
qui avait été ensevelie à la suite d'un
séisme juste l'histoire dure qu'on
m'impose moins de temps à le raconter
que d'autres pour ouvrir un cil
si vous n'aimez pas d'objets déco les
autres
alors s'il vous plaît donc là bas qu'on
reprend le clip tous les boulettes au
mexique non moi un copain à moi et au
mexique
à combien il faut aussi que les pépites
au tapis dans les décombres d'une maison
qui avait été en souvenez la suite d'un
séisme
cette petite crèche et melun rapporte en
france même si marie est dégroupé
conclura ses blagues et bat le plus que
le l'objet d'une offre quelques temps
plus tard je suis sur un lac de haute
savoie le crès tombe dans l'eau eau et
je la perds et donc je suis triste parce
que je la plus elle me plaisait bien
cette petite phrase quatre jours plus
tard je suis toujours dans le coin c'est
ça en train de faire du pédalo et
j'entends des pêcheurs dire qu'est ce
que c'est que cette merde que les filets
ont rapporté cette fois ci au pdk
[Rires]
tu peux le faire a résumé son équipement
qu'est ce que tu fais mais c'est contré
lice thomas c'est quoi l'histoire qu'est
l'art bien raconter là elle veut aller
dîner avec un garçon qu'il invite alors
qu'est ce qu'elle va raconter d'en
raconter en sous-entendus vrai j'ai bien
dit c'est quoi cet objet c'est quoi une
crèche d'église ouais mais doit la
récupérer c'était dans quel pays qu'un
mec lui a ramené quoi a pas écoutés
manou y avait un peu plus tôt la page
twitter n'a pas écouté on essaie
d'accrocher avec lui en espagne
c'est l'acte mexico sait où on met six
cobayes sceptiques
bah oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
m
on a compris mais c'est quand même sympa
bien méritée et moi parce que c'est toi
parce que c'est nous je donne je dirais
5 euros comment la passe 1 0 on va dire
10 00 ale 000 il reste ira est la robe
de kate c'est quoi ces troubles une
explication à cette robe c'est 2013 ce
qui 2013 300 millions de vues sur
internet dont c'est une des robes que je
portais pendant le clip de bella non
[Applaudissements]
c'est
donc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ben oui quoi ça larocque
oui c'est de faire ça c'est vraiment un
très jeune est vrai avec cherry s'est
longtemps elle avait des bras c'est la
vénus de l'ifo monsieur aulas
merci alors même c'est beau c'est bien
mais c'est vrai tu connaissais bella doc
gynéco ah oui il est là à marbella
exactement à vous avez pas valable
d'accord elle répond du tac elles n'ont
elles nous ont de belles là tu veux pas
là est ce que tu te peut peut-être
surenchérir sur la robe combien cette
robe là parce que c'est l'heure ça c'est
alors si on peut voir c'est du 100% et
d'installer ces sa vista ont pesé une
matière très noble est noble mais je
puis si on vous aussi on peut un peu la
main est une vraie écoute moi je
mettrais un prix correct je mettrais 50
euros en plus des 300 millions de vues
quand même le clip 50 euros je crois
qu'on va mettre plus l'accent and border
pas moi je que je me suis heureusement
sans mal sans l'euro
pour moi ça veut revendre plus cher sur
internet demandez ce que vous la vendez
la roma sans mal non donc j'ai les
causes que tu veux m un 150 150 de
l'oseille souplesse nature sacrée soirée
à tenter un sens à quotas pour gynéco
super la robe de bella
allez on y va regarder surtout que je le
savais 202 ch 200 210 g co2 sont 220 200
soldats kelly 300 mois les enchères
s'envolent 351,7 fou à l'évaluation d'un
tel eric et ben c'est une belle voie 150
350 euros 350 euros pour s'équiper
jean-michel même famille tarabin 350
euros
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tickets 10 me keddy me donne 10 363
l'a400m et l'oseille envers moi j'ai
abandonnent ou vous donner l'occasion à
400 ou doc gynéco sûr c'est beaucoup
mieux
ah ah oui ça fait et il n'avait pas
longtemps qu'il retravaille donc moi je
te l'offre si tu veux ouais mon nom et
au solaire à mon avis mais c'est quoi ce
à quoi faut l'acheter faux sirop celle
annoncée 400 euros une fois 400 euros
deux fois quatre fois trois fois
[Applaudissements]
m
mathieu mathieu que j'aurai donc c'est
non
alors je vous le dis un truc arrêtez
s'il vous plaît arrêter de bouger de
faire sans rigoler non sire il ya plein
de gens qui ont dit que c'était
insupportable vous bouger dans tous les
sens la fin d'émission c'était
insupportable et il se fout de nous
konami soirée ce soir je vous le dis il
n'y aura pas aura non il n'y aura pas de
chocolat
il n'y aura pas de chocolat en fin
d'émission il y en aura au début
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]